Isaiah Pacho is the angriest runner in
the NFL and while it's hilarious to see
all the jokes about how he runs I'll
would say the funniest one that I
thought was they said I run like I bite
people like I ain't no zombie like pe's
angry running style is a translation of
the hardships that he's been through in
life in high school peo lost both of his
siblings first his brother from a
stabbing and then his sister was
murdered just a year later he even had
to bury his sister during the day and
then play a game that night and that
Chang his outlook on life and football
forever from then peo said he vowed to
leave a all out on the field and
dedicate every run to his slain siblings
who once cheered him on and since then
pcho has run hard from high school to
college and now the pros Pacho has been
violently striking the ground with every
stride bringing back memories of past
NFL running backs who also claim to run
angry but always remember when you see p
sprinting like he's mad at the ground he
is but he does it because he doesn't
know when it could be his last and for
the people that mean to him most they
can't see him play